you mess with my pigs you mess with my
Miley Cyrus is mourning the loss of her
pet pig very special place in my in my
home on Wednesday the 26 year old took
to her Instagram story to share the sad
news that her Pig who was initially
named Bubba sue before Miley renamed the
pet pig pig has died she's a pig she
okay
Miley shared this clip writing very sad
to say my dear friend Pig pig has passed
away I will miss you always thank you
for so many laughs and good times girl
Miley also shared this shot of her
kissing pig pig snout when she was just
a baby writing I will miss you pig pig
and this snap from her paper magazine
cover shoot where she post nude with her
pet whom she got back in August 2014 so
you thought it was a mini Pig I'm like
I'm from the south we don't believe in
mini pig in 2015
Miley talked about her unusual pet
during a stop by the Tonight Show
Starring Jimmy Fallon the pig sleeps on
the couch like a bad boyfriend the pig
doesn't really want me to like hold it
or cuddle it but if I'm holding a people
okay so the other day the pig was
chasing me I was screaming it was bite
he's been back on my ankles and then I
realized I was holding a peach and I
dropped the peach and all was fine it
just wanted the peach you know so as
long as you give her food she's totally
cool she'll let you paint her nails and
all that and she's awesome
et caught up with animal trainer grant
Kemmerer in January he revealed why
celebs like Miley George Clooney Ariana
Grande and others are drawn to having
pigs as pets I think for people that
have them that have pet pigs what makes
them a good pet is they are very
personable pigs are highly intelligent
they're trainable for about anything and
that's the amazing thing about them
you
[Music]